.
TOUGH RACE.
>>> WELCOME TO "CNN TONIGHT."
I'M JAKE TAPPER.
TONIGHT, AN UNCHARACTERISTIC
WARNING FROM ONE OF THE MOST
RESPECTED NON-PARTISAN
JOURNALISTS IN THE WORLD.
BREAKING FROM 50 YEARS OF
JOURNALISTIC TRADITION TO COME
HERE AND WARN YOU ABOUT THE
THREAT HE SAYS DONALD TRUMP
POSES STILL TO THE UNITED
STATES, THREATS TO BOTH
DEMOCRACY AND TO AMERICAN
NATIONAL SECURITY.
BOB WOODWARD BECAME A HOUSEHOLD
NAME BACK IN THE '70s OF COURSE
WHEN, WITH HIS PARTNER AT THE
WASHINGTON, CARL BERNSTEIN,
WOODWARD BROKE THE WATERGATE
SCANDAL WIDE OPEN, PAVING THE
WAY TO IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS,
A BEST SELLING BOOK, AND A FILM.
>> WOODWARD, BERN TEEN, YOU'RE
BOTH ON THE STORY SO DON'T
[ BLEEP ] IT UP.
>> SINCE THEN, WOODWARD HAS
BECOME AN AUTHORITY ON THE
PRESIDENCY, PUBLISHING MORE THAN
A DOZEN LOOKS WITH UNVARNISHED
LOOKS AT REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
HIS ACCESS IS UNMATCHED.
THERE'S AN OLD SAYING IN
JOURNALISM, IF YOUR MOTHER SAYS
SHE LOVES YOU, GET A SECOND
SOURCE.
HE LISTENS TO PRESIDENTS, WRITES
DOWN WHAT HE TELLS THEM, AND HE
CHECKS WHEN THEY SAY WITH THOSE
IN THE ROOM WHERE IT HAPPENED.
NOW WOODWARD IS RELEASING AUDIO,
AUDIO FROM THE MORE THAN EIGHT
HOURS OF DISCUSSIONS HE HAD WITH
CANDIDATE AND PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP.
WHILE SOME OF THE CONTENT HAS
BEEN REPORTED ON BEFORE,
WOODWARD WANTS YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, TO HEAR FROM DONALD
TRUMP DIRECTLY TO SEE IF YOU
COME TO THE SAME CONCLUSIONS
THAT HE HAS, THAT, QUOTE, THE
RECORD NOW SHOWS THAT TRUMP HAS
LED AND CONTINUES TO LEAD A
SEDITIOUS CONSPIRACY TO OVERTURN
THE 2020 ELECTION, WHICH IN
EFFECT, IS AN EFFORT TO DESTROY
DEMOCRACY, UNQUOTE.
THOSE ARE SHOCKING WORDS FROM
BOB WOODWARD.
AN EFFORT TO DESTROY DEMOCRACY?
SEDITIOUS CONSPIRACY?
WHY IS WOODWARD SAYING THIS NOW?
WE WILL ASK HIM HERE LIVE IN A
MOMENT.
BUT FIRST, WE NEED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IT'S NOT AS THOUGH
TRUMP STOPPED SAYING OUTRAGEOUS,
DANGEROUS THINGS.
HE SIMPLY LOST ACCESS TO HIS
MORE MAIN STREAM UNFILTERED
MEGAPHONES, WHETHER TWITTER OR
FACEBOOK OR A LIVE FEED FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE LAWN.
FEW MEDIA OUTLETS CONTINUE TO
COVER HIS EVERY SPEECH OR EVERY
UNTETHERED POST ON HIS
IRONICALLY NAMED TRUTH SOCIAL
TWITTER KNOCKOFF.
BUT IN SOME WAYS, TRUMP'S
RHETORIC, FOR THOSE OF US WHO
HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING IT, IT HAS,
DARE I SAY, GOTTEN WORSE.
CASE AND POINT, WHAT DONALD
TRUMP SAID AT A RALLY OVER THE
WEEKEND IN TEXAS ABOUT HOW HE
WOULD HANDLE THE JOURNALISTS AND
THE PUBLISHER OF POLITICO WHO
BROKE THE STORY OF THE SUPREME
COURT DRAFT OPINION OVERTURNING
ROE V. WADE.
THIS IS HOW DONALD TRUMP SAID HE
WOULD FORCE THOSE JOURNALISTS TO
GIVE HIM THE NAME OF THEIR
SOURCE.
>> SAY, WHO IS THE LEAKER?
NATIONAL SECURITY.
AND THEY SAY, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
TELL YOU.
THEY SAY, THAT'S OKAY.
YOU'RE GOING TO JAIL.
AND WHEN THIS PERSON REALIZES
THAT HE IS GOING TO BE THE BRIDE
OF ANOTHER PRISONER VERY
SHORTLY, HE WILL SAY, I'D VERY
MUCH LIKE TO TELL YOU EXACTLY
WHO THAT LEAKER -- IT WAS BILL
JONES.
I SWEAR HE'S THE LEAKER, AND WE
GOT HIM.
>> WE GOT HIM.
THE RALLY CROWD LAUGHING ALONG
THERE AT DONALD TRUMP TALKING
ABOUT THREATENING A REPORTER
WITH PRISONERY.
LET'S YOU THINK THIS IS CLASSIC
TRUMP SPOUTING OFF TRYING TO
MAKE THE CROWD LAUGH.
DONNY FROM QUEENS SAYING FOLKS
WHO KNOW TRUMP WELL AFRAID.
HERE'S ALYSSA FARAH GRIFFIN, WHO
WORRIES IF TRUMP MANAGES TO
BECOME PRESIDENT AGAIN, HIS
SEQUEL WILL BE ALL ABOUT
RETRIBUTION AND CHANGING AMERICA
FOREVER.
>> YOU THINK HE WILL TRY TO
IMPOSE SOME FORM OF AUTOCRACY.
>> I THINK HE ABSOLUTELY WOULD.
THERE ARE THINGS HE WANTED TO DO
WHEN HE WAS IN POWER THE FIRST
TIME THAT WERE WELL BEYOND THE
SCOPE OF WHAT THE U.S. PRESIDENT
SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO, WHETHER
IT'S WEAPONIZING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AGAINST POLITICAL
OPPONENTS, WHETHER IT'S, YOU
KNOW, GOING AFTER THE FREE
PRESS, HE WOULD CERTAINLY BE
OPEN TO USING THE MILITARY FOR
POLITICAL REASONS AS WELL.
>> SO, KEEP THAT IN MIND FROM
FORMER TRUMP INSIDERS, THAT
CONCERN, WHEN WE LISTEN TO THE
TRUMP INTERVIEWS WITH BOB
WOODWARD.
WHAT DID TRUMP SAY THAT CAUSED A
SEASONED, STRAIGHT DOWN THE
MIDDLE JOURNALIST TO BREAK THE
GLASS IN CASE OF EMERGENCY?
LET'S START WITH THE CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC, WHICH HAS NOW KILLED
MORE THAN 1 MILLION PEOPLE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
THE TAPES SEEM TO REVEAL A
PRESIDENT WHO WAS CAUGHT
COMPLETELY UNDERPREPARED AND DID
VERY LITTLE IN THOSE FIRST
CRUCIAL MONTHS TO COURSE CORRECT
EVEN THOUGH TWO OF TRUMP'S TOP
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISERS TOLD
WOODWARD DIRECTLY THAT THEY GAVE
DONALD TRUMP A CLEAR AND DIRECT
WARNING ON JANUARY 28, 2020.
>> SO, I THEN JUMPED IN AND I
THINK THE PHRASE I USED WAS THIS
WILL BE THE BIGGEST NATIONAL
SECURITY THREAT YOU'LL FACE IN
YOUR PRESIDENCY.
>> YOU WERE LITERALLY SAYING TO
THE PRESIDENT THIS WILL BE THE
BIGGEST NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT
YOU FACE IN YOUR PRESIDENCY?
>> YES, YES, YES.
>> A WARNING, JANUARY 28, 2020.
HERE'S HOW TRUMP RESPONDED IN
MAY, WHEN WOODWARD LEARNED ABOUT
THAT WARNING AND ASKED TRUMP
ABOUT IT.
>> YOUR NEW NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER, O'BRIEN --
>> RIGHT.
>> -- SAID JANUARY 28,
MR. PRESIDENT, THIS VIRUS IS
GOING TO BE THE BIGGEST NATIONAL
SECURITY THREAT TO YOUR
PRESIDENCY.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT?
>> NO, NO.
NO, I DON'T.
I'M SURE HE SAID IT.
YOU KNOW, I'M SURE HE SAID IT.
NICE GUY.
>> AS I SAID, WOODWARD HAD NOT
LEARNED ABOUT THE JANUARY 28th
WARNING UNTIL MAY.
MAY.
MORE THAN 70,000 AMERICANS HAD
ALREADY DIED FROM THE VIRUS.
TWO MONTHS AFTER THAT IN JULY,
TRUMP GAVE WOODWARD A RING, AND
HE SAID HE FINALLY HAD A PLAN TO
DEAL WITH THE PANDEMIC.
BUT TRUMP WANTED TO WAIT TO
RELEASE IT UNTIL A TIME WHEN IT
WOULD BETTER HELP HIM WIN
RE-ELECTION.
>> THE PLAN OVER THE NEXT FOUR
WEEKS -- BOB, I'VE GOT 106 DAYS.
THAT'S A LONG TIME.
YOU KNOW, IF I PUT OUT A PLAN
NOW, PEOPLE WON'T EVEN REMEMBER
IT IN 100 -- I WON THE LAST
ELECTION --
>> NO, NO.
IT'S NOT JUST PUT OUT THE PLAN.
IT'S EXECUTE IT.
>> I AM EXECUTING -- YOU'LL SEE
IT STARTING --
>> BUT IT WAS NOT JUST TRUMP'S
HANDLING OF THE PANDEMIC THAT
LED WOODWARD TO DECLARE HIM AN
UNPARALLELED DANGER.
BACK IN DECEMBER 2019, TRUMP
SHARED LETTERS WITH WOODWARD
THAT HAD BEEN SENT BY NORTH
KOREAN DICTATOR KIM JONG-UN.
>> HE WROTE ME BEAUTIFUL
LETTERS.
AND THEY'RE GREAT LETTERS.
WE FELL IN LOVE.
>> WE FELL IN LOVE.
KIM JONG-UN IS OF COURSE A
MURDEROUS TYRANT WHOSE CITIZENS
ARE ESSENTIALLY PRISONERS IN
THEIR OWN COUNTRY.
TRUMP DID NOT ACTUALLY SEEM TO
CARE MUCH ABOUT THAT, THOUGH.
TO WOODWARD, TRUMP ONLY CARED
ABOUT DICTATORS IN TERM OF THEIR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH HIM.
>> IT'S FUNNY, THE RELATIONSHIP
S I HAVE, THE MEANER THEY ARE,
THE BETTER I GET ALONG WITH.
YOU'LL EXPLAIN THAT TO ME
SOMEDAY.
THE EASIER ONES ARE THE ONES I
DON'T GET ALONG WITH AS MUCH.
>> THAT'S ANOTHER TRAIT THAT
ALARMED WOODWARD ALONG WITH
OTHER NATIONAL SECURITY EXPERTS.
TRUMP HAD A FAILURE TO
UNDERSTAND THE ROLE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
PLAYS ON THE GLOBAL STAGE.
THIS IS WHAT TRUMP WAS SAYING
ABOUT PUTIN IN 2019.
>> I RESPECT PUTIN.
I THINK PUTIN LIKES ME.
I THINK I LIKE HIM.
>> BOTH RELATION PSHIPS, TRUMP
AND PUTIN AND TRUMP AND KIM
JONG-UN CONTINUED TO BLOSSOM
THROUGHOUT HIS PRESIDENCY.
WITH WOODWARD IN DECEMBER 2019.
>> THE WORD, CHEMISTRY, YOU MEET
SOMEBODY, AND YOU HAVE A GOOD
CHEMISTRY.
YOU MEET A WOMAN.
IN ONE SECOND, YOU KNOW WHETHER
OR NOT IT'S ALL GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> YOU MEET A WOMAN.
IN ONE SECOND, YOU KNOW WHETHER
OR NOT IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
THAT IS ESPECIALLY TRUE, BY THE
WAY, PER THE "ACCESS HOLLYWOOD"
TAPES AND A MYRIAD OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT ACCUSATIONS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE LEADER
OF THE FREE WORLD MAKING FOREIGN
POLICIES BASED ON HIS
PERCEPTIONS OF CHEMISTRY.
NOW, FOR WOODWARD, HEARING IS
BELIEVING.
THAT'S WHY HE'S HERE TONIGHT.
SO, YOU CANNOT JUST READ ABOUT
BUT LISTEN TO DONALD TRUMP, WHO
FOR INSTANCE SEEMED TO HAVE
LITTLE INTEREST IN HELPING
BATTLE THE BIGGEST PANDEMIC THE
WORLD HAS SEEN SINCE 1918.
PERHAPS THE MOST TELLING PART OF
THE TRUMP TAPES, HOWEVER, IS
WHAT TRUMP WOULD NOT SAY.
WOODWARD SAYS THAT IN ALL 20
INTERVIEWS, THERE'S ONLY ONE
TIME DONALD TRUMP ESSENTIALLY
SAID, NO COMMENT.
IN SUMMER 2020, AROUND THE TIME
THAT THE JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE
SAYS, TRUMP AND HIS MINIONS WERE
BEGINNING THE PLAN TO HOLD ON TO
POWER ILLEGALLY AND VIOLENTLY
AND AT ALL COSTS.
>> EVERYONE SAYS TRUMP IS GOING
TO STAY IN THE WHITE HOUSE IF
IT'S CONTESTED.
>> WELL, I'M NOT -- I DON'T WANT
TO EVEN COMMENT ON THAT.
>> SURE.
>> I DON'T WANT TO COMMENT ON
THAT AT THIS TIME.
HEY, BOB, I'VE GOT A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
I'LL TALK TO YOU LATER ON
TONIGHT.
>> WE KNOW NOW WHY TRUMP
WOULDN'T ANSWER THAT ONE
QUESTION, HIS PLANS TO STAY IN
POWER, TO TRY TO THROW OUT
MILLIONS OF AMERICAN VOTES, TO
TRY AND SUBVERT AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY, ENDING IN THE DEADLY
AND BLOODY INSURRECTION.
THAT IS JUST ONE OF